[Music]
reactome is a free
manually curated knowledge base that
provides a user-friendly platform to
access and analyze information on
molecular mechanisms of reactions
and pathways it provides highly detailed
pathway diagrams of molecular processes
and descriptions available via the react
home website
and to download in standard formats such
as biopacks and sbml
the basic unit of reactome is a reaction
which is defined as any molecular event
including binding phosphorylation
biochemical catalysis
molecular transport and spontaneous
molecular events
these reactions can involve any
biological molecule but are typically
proteins in small molecules
a pathway is defined as a series of
connected reactions
with each individual reaction considered
as a single step in the pathway
these are represented as pathways in
detailed molecular diagrams
examples of pathways include immune
system signaling
the cell cycle and apoptosis in reactome
we create pathways using reactions as
building blocks
reactions are interconnected based on
biological relevance resulting in the
formation of pathways
the key aspects of reactome content are
quality and attribution
pathways are written by expert
biologists and independently
peer-reviewed before being included in
the database
reactions always cite scientific
literature that experimentally verifies
the described event
these manually curated human pathways
are used as templates to computationally
infer equivalent pathways in other
species
including most commonly used model
organisms
high throughput technologies allow
researchers to identify gene regulation
markers and determine gene expression
protein and metabolite levels for many
thousands of molecules in a single
experiment
generating huge amounts of data
interpreting these data requires an
understanding of the connections between
these molecules
an effective way to do this is to
integrate experimental information with
well-annotated established pathway data
reacttone fulfills this need by
providing free access to detailed
pathways combined with analytical tools
reactome includes tools for analyzing
the pathway context of your data
mapping expression or other quantitative
data onto pathways or extending pathways
with interactions from external
databases
there are two ways to access the
analysis submission form
either clicking the analyze data button
on the home page or using the analysis
button on the pathway browser header bar
upon clicking the analyze data an
interface pops out where you can submit
your data and perform various analyses
the tabs on the left of this interface
indicate the different types of analyses
analyze gene list or analyze gene
expression will perform
pathway enrichment analysis
species comparison will compare human
pathways with other species
tissue distribution will compare
pathways in various tissue types
you can select the analysis you want to
perform paste in or browse for a file
containing your data
or use an example data set